okay I told you yesterday that Donald
Trump met for the first time with
congressional lawmakers used it as an
opportunity to again parrot this widely
debunked bogus fake notion that three to
five million undocumented immigrants
voted for Hillary Clinton and that only
because of that did Donald Trump lose
the popular vote on paper a number of
investigations into this mostly
Republican secretaries of state around
the around the United States have said
no we have no evidence of this voters
voted fraud that Donald Trump is talking
about there never has been significant
voter fraud in the way that Donald Trump
talks about a notable case actually was
of a Republican getting caught as Pat
mentioned yesterday a Republican who was
trying to prove some kind of point by
voting twice but she actually got caught
and and she was arrested for it Trump
press secretary Sean Spicer was asked to
justify what Donald Trump said he was
completely unable to check out this
non-defense when he was asked for
evidence the President does believe that
he has stated that before I think he
stated his concerns voter fraud and
people voting illegally during the
campaign and he continues to maintain
that belief based on studies and
evidence that people are presented to
him that they don't I think the
president has believed that for a while
based on studies information he has
based on studies and evidence that Trump
has which I won't name this is what he's
believed so Sean Spicer doubled down on
the comment and then now Trump is
tripling down on the comment calling for
a major investigation here's two tweets
Trump sent in the recent hours
back-to-back quote I will be asking for
a major investigation into voter fraud
including those registered to vote in
two states those who are illegal and
even those registered to vote who were
dead and many for a long time depending
on results we will strengthen up voting
procedures strengthen up voting
procedures I'm gonna talk about that in
a second hey what about fiscal
conservatism Pat a major investigation
into something that's been looked into
cow
this times already it doesn't sound
cheap and I thought this was the party
of fiscal responsibility well it's also
just funny how Trump and his surrogates
have been going around the past couple
months claiming they won the election in
this big landslide and that they have
this big mandate but now he's
questioning the legitimacy of his own
election I mean which one is it done
yeah I'm gonna get to that because
that's fascinating and we know exactly
what will happen with this investigation
they'll find a few random sporadic cases
of so-called voter fraud some recently
dead people who were still on the voter
rolls some college students who were
registered to vote both in the state
they grew up in and in the state where
they're going to college even though
they only actually voted one time and
then they will use these completely
sporadic and insignificant instances of
quote voter fraud to increase voter ID
rules make it even harder for people to
vote Trump will claim to be vindicated
that's what's going to happen and look
at what Republicans have been able to
pass in terms of voter ID without a
presidential edom and that investigation
into voter fraud even if the
investigation turns up ten instances of
so-called voter fraud double
registrations or dead people on the
rolls etc it will be used to justify
more restrictions and who will be hurt
by that Pat progressives and you gotta
love house Sean Spicer is not providing
any evidence whatsoever one of the
biggest pieces of evidence we do have on
this topic comes from the Brennan Center
of Justice and they found that from 22
from 2000 to 2014 there were 31
instances of Rota fraud out of a billion
votes cast yeah
31 over a 12-year period and think about
the Trump back-and-forth this is where
it just gets great before the election
Donald Trump saying hey the election is
rigged this is a rigged election then
Donald Trump wins the election Donald
Trump says the election was not rigged
I'm a legitimate president he then finds
out that his popular vote deficit has
been growing and growing and growing to
nearly 3 million votes now it's rigged
again were 3 to 5 million undocumented
immigrants voted oh but Russia was
accused of hacking the election Russia
influenced the result Trump goes back to
nope not rigged I won fair and square
it's all good then he gets inaugurated
and people see him as illegitimate and
there's a number of insiders who were
saying Trump's really panicking
that voters many voters see him as
illegitimate now the elections back to
rigged accord rigged according to Donald
Trump because of these three to five
million non-existent votes by
undocumented immigrants what do you do
if you're another Republican you control
the White House House and Senate and the
president is talking about widely
debunked voter fraud conspiracy theories
it's important to remember the
information warfare which is effectively
what all of this this alternative fact
stuff is from the Trump administration
it's not necessarily about creating an
alternate truth that they want everybody
to believe it's about eroding the
average person's ability to know what's
truth and what's propaganda it's not
propaganda in the sense that if the
average person doesn't know what to
trust it's all possible and that is
really the underlying damage that this
entire alternative fact repeating widely
debunked and provably provably false
narratives that's the danger of that
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman today's show is brought to you
by go daddy where you can buy your own
domain name build a website or use any
of Go Daddy's business tools you can
save 30 percent at Tri godaddy.com slash
David GoDaddy has actually been the
official host of the David Pakman show
web site for many many many years the
24/7 customer support has been a very
good thing for us I've called them at
really odd times when we've had website
issues and they are always available
they are the largest domain registrar
and whether you have a new idea you're
an established business you're creating
a personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to GoDaddy they can
do it all thirteen million customers try
it and get thirty percent off at try go
daddy.com slash david